do you phyllis take bob vance vance
refrigeration to be your lawfully wedded
husband
i do ladies and gentlemen may i present
to you for the first time as a couple mr
and mrs bob vance
and do you bob take phyllis to be your
lawfully wedded wife
i do
you may now kiss the boy ladies and
gentlemen for the first time as a couple
mr
mrs
[Applause]
go tell somebody
what andy
andy what should i tell them don't tell
them i'm floating away obviously
i don't understand what you want from me
angela it's pretty simple look at what
i'm doing and go tell somebody it
sorry
we are in a stairwell
we are climbing some stairs
i'm breathing heavily okay you know what
you really don't need to be updating me
as much as you're updating oh there's a
guy there's a guy it's a security guard
coming by okay
hello we're warehouse workers
would you like more proof
hey
oh my god that was very close i could
see the security guard's eyes no no
don't do anything to them
i have to do something to his eyes the
eyes
are the groin of the head
all right great scott if you found that
choking hazard poster just head on home
we got something far better their crown
jewel
their industrial copier
isn't that thing huge
it's enormous
but it's got wheels we're wheeling it
down the hall
into the stairwell get the car ready
keep the engine running
no that is a terrible idea don't do this
my headphones we're watching between the
cup here in the rally oh god
yeah my leg jim leave us jim help leave
us now save yourself don't leave us help
us we need help jim okay first of all
stop using my name and second of all
you gotta move damn it guys
oh my god oh my god karen is back
take her to a motel make love to her
no i'm not doing that
just say you want to get back together
no i'm not doing that it doesn't have to
mean anything just
do it for stan lee
come on jim just climb on top of her
think about stanley oh god
oh jim
if this is it for me promise me
something
jim what's the dummies
hey karen
at least once a year i like to bring in
some of my kevin's famous chili
the trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot
i'm serious about this stuff
i'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes
i toast my own ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
what is this
happy holidays dwight
but do not open it until christmas you
were so pathetic how long did this take
you three hours five minutes actually
i am a black belt in gift wrapping yeah
no such thing they don't give out black
belts for things that are stupid
well i hope it was worth it because i'm
gonna take it apart in about five
minutes
i think i'll take you a little bit
longer than that really if i can skin a
mule deer in less than 10 minutes i
ought to be able to cut my legs
proceed straight
well we're all for six
last chance is the elmhurst country club
other side of the lake on the southeast
side i don't get it
i really don't get it i thought this
would work
do everything i had at that guy nothing
that's how it goes sometimes you know
you lose everything and everything falls
apart and eventually you die and no one
remembers you that is a very good point
dwight make a right turn
wait wait wait wait no no no no it means
bear right
not there it said right it said take a
right
no no no no no look it it means go up to
the right bear right over the bridge and
hook up with 307. make a right maybe
it's a shortcut dwight it's say go to
the right it can't mean that there's a
leg there he knows where it is
remain calm i have trained for this
okay
exit the window here we go make
[Music]
come
on
come on
oh
in the parking lot today there was a
circus
copier did tricks on the high wire a
lady tried to give away a baby that
looked like a cat there was a dwight
impersonator and a gym impersonator a
strong man crushed a turtle i laughed
and i cried
not bad for a day in the life of a dog
food company
oh jim hey hey toby there's this female
uh stenographer at the courthouse no one
looks exactly like you that's incredible
yeah no it's on camera you know what's
crazy i can't reconnect with you right
now hold on one second
[Music]
oh
excuse me
okay that's about as good as that's
gonna be okay now here's the plan i'm
gonna launch him i need you to go down
to the bottom and catch him catch yeah i
can't catch him he's like 250 pounds use
your hands and just blunt his descent
okay he's gonna be moving slowly it's
only one it's 15 feet down it's at a 45
degree angle get set in your haunches
it's like you're catching a medicine the
size of my lunches
okay um michael the custodian from
raskin design is on the line he said
they found your keys in the koi pond
okay thank you
did you say koi pond
yeah michael people are asking questions
uh okay put them on speaker hey guys
what's going on hey michael did you fall
into a koi pond ah i can't really hear
you i i think we sort of have a bad
connection jim did michael fall into a
koi pond
it's like michael said it was um
some something else it was okay this is
what it was it was these bunch of idiots
that had put a fish tank in the ground
with no cover and no railing so you fell
in no maybe i was trying to save a child
that had fallen in so a child had fallen
in not yet that is hilarious no it don't
i'm not gonna bump i'm not gonna bump it
it was not hilarious it was very very
terrifying truthfully it wasn't the way
he fell in it was
how long it took him to get out
okay we all go together or we go one at
a time here it is here it is uh truck to
refrigerators to dumpster 360 spin onto
the palace backflip gainer into the
trash
hardcore
parkour behind you come on
yeah
you